We hear a lot about genius. We are taught
to admire the minds of those infinite, baffling
but astonishing geniuses like Einstein, Tolstoy
or Picasso. Quite what genius might actually
be is left a little vague. It’s a codeword
for ‘brilliant but perhaps too other-worldly
ever really to fathom.’ We are invited to
stand in awe at the achievements of geniuses
but also to feel that their thought processes
might be quasi-magical and that it is ultimately
simply mysterious how they were ever able
to come up with the ideas they have had. But
there is a radically different view, suggested
by a hugely prescient quote from the 19th
century American genius Ralph Waldo Emerson:
In the minds of geniuses, we find – once
more – our own neglected thoughts. What
this tells us is that the genius doesn’t
have different kinds of thoughts from the
rest of us. They simply take them more seriously.
We ourselves will often have had our own sketchy,
hesitant version of their ideas – which
is why their works can have such a distinctive
impression on us. What they present feels
surprising and impressive, of course; yet
also obvious and right – once it has been
pointed out. They are giving clear and powerful
articulation to notions that are already familiar
because we’ve been circling them ourselves,
possibly for years, without quite ever being
able to close in on them properly. Genius
can in this sense be defined as paying closer
attention to our real thoughts and feelings
and being brave and tenacious enough to hold
onto them even when they find no immediate
echo in the world beyond. The reason why we
disavow so much of what passes through our
minds is in essence anxiety. We kill off our
most promising thoughts for fear of seeming
strange to ourselves and others (which explains
why small children are, in their own way,
so much more interesting than the average
adult: they have not yet become experts in
what not to say or think). But when we censor
and close down, when we take fright and try
not to think, is exactly the moment when the
so-called genius starts to take note of what
is happening within their mind. We operate with
a false picture of genius when we identify
it too strongly with what is exotic and utterly
beyond us. It is something far more provocative
than this. Genius is what we all can be when
we pay careful attention to what is truly
passing through consciousness. We all have
very similar and very able minds; where geniuses
differ is in their more robust inclinations
to study them properly.
We love bringing you these films.  If you want to help us to keep bringing you thoughtful content
please consider supporting us, at the link on your screen now.